Now it's no secret, the Y chromosome is so
much smaller than the X chromosome. And there's an amazingly
cool story behind all of this. Please go read about
it. It's amazing. It's been going on for a long
time. The Y chromosome has been getting smaller and
smaller for the last oh, I don't know 100 million
years or so. But the result has had dramatic implications
for genes that are expressed from the X chromosome and
they don't exist on the Y chromosome. Think about it
for a second. Let's say we're interested in this gene
that causes red green colorblindness and it's on the X
chromosome. Well, females have two X chromosomes. So anytime we're
looking at their inheritance patterns. It's pretty much the same
thing and straightforward as we've ever looked at for the
autosomes, because females have two copies. They have two alleles,
they can be homozygous they can be heterozygous, they can be
plus, plus, plus minus, or minus, minus. And for
recessive traits, when they're homozygous recessive, then they're going to show
the trait, let's say, for red green color blindness. But
for the sake of it, let's say that the female
is heterozygous, dominant recessive. So they're not actually red-green
colorblind, but they carry an allele for it. Males don't
have that luxury. It's almost like the females have a
backup copy, functioning copy of the gene, so they aren't
red-green colorblind. But males sure they have one X
chromosome. The Y chromosome is missing the piece of information
that would correlate to the same region on the X
chromosome. They don't have this gene. So if the male
has the dominant copy grade, he's going to see color
vision just fine. But if he inherits even just one
allele, one recessive allele for red-green colorblindness, that's all it
takes. He doesn't have anything to counteract the effect, and
so he's going to be red-green colorblind. So in our
pedigree up at the top here, we have an affected
great-grandfather. And if he is XY, we know that
he has an affected allele. If he has any daughter,
he must pass that allele on, because both daughters
are XX. They get one X from mom and one
X from dad. And the X that came from dad
had to have been the one with the recessive alleles.
So both of these daughters are carriers. They have to be,
because we know they're unaffected. See they're not shaded, that means
they're not red green colorblind. It must have gotten the recessive
allele from their father. And then if we look at this individual's
children here, these two. She had an unaffected daughter, we have
no idea if she passed on the recessive allele or not
because it's masked. But in the case of her son, we
see very clearly, he must have the recessive allele because he's affected.
So, although the trait looks like it skipped a
generation, right? It looks like it went from grandfather
to grandson. The allele didn't skip anybody, the allele
went right from grandfather to mother to son. You
can see it, you can track it in the pedigree. So the lesson from all of this is
that, although phenotypes appear to skip generation sometimes, the
alleles never skip. And in the case of sex-linked traits,
when they're linked to either the X or the Y chromosome,
because there're some traits linked only to the Y chromosome. The
patterns can be a little bit more tricky to discern because
the males don't have another copy to complement their X chromosome.